so what you're suggesting is people's
diets and lifestyle have contributed to
crooked teeth over by its under bites
and just generally misshapen faces yeah
you're not necessarily an ugly person
you just haven't been what holding your
tongue properly if you're an adult and
you want to become more attractive or
fix your jaw or get a stronger jaw what
exactly do you do okay so this is the
big multi-million dollar question a face
that's not the right shape doesn't work
properly
[Music]
this episode features Dr Mike Mew who's
behind the viral mewing for an
attractive jaw craze his dad John mu
came up with mewing a way to prevent and
potentially fix crooked teeth and
improve your health and the way you
breathe and look it's pretty
revolutionary very aligned with
ancestral living if you're into that it
makes more sense to me if you watch the
episode and decide you'd like to support
Mike there's a petition linked below at
preventcrooked teeth.com you can sign
enjoy and let me know what you think of
this is there anything you specifically
want to talk about I saw that you're
being investigated well you know it's
it's you know again you know I just I
was I was interested with the parallels
with the fact your father's being
investigated and you know
this is It's a system against the new
idea you know I'm breaking the mold when
they want to shut me up basically
because and they've got it's just so
unfair you know they have all of uh um
everything in their favor and you know
it'd just be difficult being the little
guy trying to
put something forward but you know my
central theme you know has been to
trying to debate why Artie crooked you
know I've been trying to engage my
profession and debate I'm saying look
don't listen to anything you know listen
to word I've got to say but believe that
I want the scientific process I want a
debate on white people crooked and then
we work upwards you know you start with
utility and if you're treating all these
kids and you you openly admit you've got
no idea what causes the problem
yeah no and there is so much more to
this mewing clearly I wasn't expecting
viewing it's sort of
I guess I was very lucky you know you
you've got
recognized when you're being lucky and I
guess make most of it because I have
been lucky and this is helping me get
that message out there but really what
it is something's going wrong with the
way people's faces are growing and
it's people don't want to admit this
even want to be people want to believe
that the way their face grew with
genetic and that's it
and yet it's so clearly not genetic and
all the hard evidence says it's not
genetic
but you've got a profession about quite
a few professions when you analyze it
that are looking
that up
they're predicated word I learned from
your father
um
this problem you know crooked teeth or
sleep apnea or the way your face grows
and lots of ENT problems and George on
problems the the inferences that
these are caused by the it's genetics at
least that's the way we're treating it
as if it were caused by the genetics and
yet all hard evidence says that it's not
caused by genetics
and
medicine doesn't like to change
you know has a great inertia against
change I mean you you know this
and
there's inevitable pushback and of
course
I I what I really really annoys me I
mean the biggest thing I really want to
push is prevention yeah because I think
that
we could
I don't know if you could completely
prevent it on a modern world but I'm
sure you could make a lot of effort to
reduce the severity of these problems
with simple Public Health messages like
eat with your mouth shut
stand up straight and shut your mouth
that's not a new idea
and
it's it's just getting that message out
there
and really making parents of children
aware of the amount they can do to
ensure that their child grows closer to
their full genetic potential
because a face that is the right shape
grew well is a health for your face
but unfortunately a healthier face is
also an attractive face
you know I think that we're hardwired to
be attracted to healthy people in many
ways
that may be
is what attraction is and attractiveness
is Health in many other ways
but of course it's also a motive
you know it suddenly becomes emotional I
remember you before
I became famous or before I had a
following parents would bring their
child to see me
and you know the mother would laugh at
how crooked their child's teeth were
and then I would start explaining the
philosophy and the concept behind what
we were thinking and the penny would
then drop in the mother that I was
suggesting that their child's face
hadn't grown me yeah and they'd have a
sense of they'd have a sense of humor
failure
and I had one mother lead you know I
couldn't be lighter I couldn't be nicer
and I'm saying more
you know how how do you Circle that
square you know and I walk down the
street and I'm seeing a train wreck a
disaster car accident and it's everyone
I meet everyone's faces yeah
you know and we know how they should
grow because we've got the skulls go go
look they're in the museums and you know
it's the same you see that guy walking
off the African Serengeti you know
Boulders brass you know fantastic really
broad smile with all 13 teeth and
usually something like a centimeter
behind the wisdom teeth wow that's a
vast amount of tongue space yeah for his
tongue
and
interestingly
they look just like our ancestors
and we don't look like our ancestors
and there's been this huge change and no
one's pointing it out no one's saying
hello well people are I mean I don't
you're familiar with the book Jaws
done gossip
um yes I have it's popping up my mic at
the moment
laughs
I don't even believe that you know this
book here this this is basically my
father's concept yep taken by Sandra
Khan and Paul Ehrlich so Paul Ehrlich at
Stanford who came out with the
population bomb yeah and
you know they produce that the book and
it that is you know Paul came to our
house I mean I've known Sandra for years
and he wanted to put this story together
and present the story
and you know it's there it's a Well
documented it's well researched it's you
know I would wish I had time to write a
book like that myself
it
you know it's there it's scientifically
valid
but it's too much it's it's too much of
a destructive idea
it damages
too many people's
status quo and professions and
qualifications and
income you know the
the resistance is large hey guys if you
enjoy a few glasses of wine once a week
or a drink at any point in your life in
any amount you need to try the
supplement I launched after party it
helps you break down acetaldehyde which
is the toxin that alcohol ethanol
converts into in your body when you
drink that poisons you and leads to
alcohol damage the supplement is made of
dihydramyrisotin
which is a terrible name for a
supplement which is why we called it
after party which also works weekly on
Gaba so it can help with anxiety
following drinking as well if that's
something that bugs you obviously don't
abuse alcohol but if you're into
biohacking and you don't have a hangover
pill you're doing it wrong you could say
you're doing biohacking wrong if you
drink anything but hey Life Is Life
sometimes people want to have a few
drinks
smartdrugs.life code MP for 15 off and
you can try it for 30 days completely
risk-free because we'll give you your
money back if you don't want it
obviously there's no point in getting
wasted so don't do that but there's also
no point in drinking any amount
without helping your body break down
acetaldehyde so try it out
smartdrugs.life code MP for 15 off I
hope you enjoy the rest of this episode
yeah well what it's suggesting is that
you can change this the shape of your
skull right basically yes this is the
thing you know you you start saying well
if this is an environmental
change
then you can change your environment
and thus you can change your your facial
form
and
this this sounds radical but look at
anyone who has a stroke
yeah and you see one side it says you
know I'm right
but it is one of those things that just
jars with people people
you know
you know that image that looks back to
you from any mirror in the world
you know what's on what bit of your
passport or a driving license to people
look at when they want to identify you
it's your photograph it's your face in
many ways you could say that is your
identity
for me to come along and say that thing
that you think your identity is it's
plastic
you know you know you can change your
face you know it's like you can change
your personality you're not the same
person yeah
it's just all these layers of emotive
and I'm sure
I'm sure I'm gonna be burned alive by
people are saying oh
you should be happy
the Way You Are
you know you should and
what am I saying I'm coming along saying
that well actually
you can change the very essence of what
you think is you is malleable it's
mobile
and if your face hasn't grown very well
not only is it probably your or even
worse your parents fault
but it's probably causing you serious
health problems I can see why there's a
little bit of pushback from people yeah
okay okay well let's get started with
then
how do you so what you're suggesting is
people's diets and lifestyle have
contributed to malocclusion crooked
teeth
overbites under bites and just generally
misshapen faces and so you're not
necessarily you're not necessarily an
ugly person he you just haven't been
what holding your tongue properly what's
gone wrong
okay so when you know the the important
question always and that's is what
caused this problem because medicine's
supposed to be about treating the causes
of problems
now well I couldn't tell you if our
ancestors had sleep apnea couldn't tell
you if they had type 2 diabetes we we
don't know but they're dead and there's
no soft tissue left and we don't have
contemporaneous records of taken at the
time
what we do have though is all these
skulls
so I can tell you precisely where the
teeth were or still are
and I can also tell you precisely that
the dimensions of the shapes of skulls
and what you see when you go back in
skull records is the further back you go
the more Conformity there was and the
better
architecture of the face there was
yeah I mean in all racial groups all the
way around the world it is not a racial
theme you know this really is just skin
deep and
then you go to start looking at what
environment what's changed what's
changed what are the major factors that
have changed that period from when we
were hunter-gatherers to the modern
environment and the the two I mean
there's quite a lot of factors but the
two really big factors seem to be that
we've gone from this really tough hard
rough diet where you need to eat a lot
you needed to eat a lot to gain the
calories you needed for the day
and we've gone across to this diet that
is just Ubisoft
and it's I say it's very calorie Rich
you could have so I could make you a
drink you know I I I've looked this up
you know a Starbucks
um White Cafe mocker is I think 420
calories
well that's before you start oh put some
marshmallows and cream and some sweet
you know um syrups in there I mean you
you could get that out easily to a
quarter if not a third of your calorific
not not nutritional but just the
calories you need for the day
and to gain those calories you've done
during no effort no no match to catering
effort you've not used these puppies
here you've not used them at all to get
those calories on board so either that
day you're going to eat more stuff to
use your muscles and then put on weight
because you're taking too many calories
on board
or you're going to eat less you know you
don't eat as much that day to compensate
for those cows the easy calories you've
done
and that's what's happening you know
we're giving you you see the amount of
sugar that's creeping into Foods
well the amount of effort
is going down
um
I remember a lecturer telling me that
our ancestors were eating for up to a
third of the day wow
no that that's a huge amount of effort
that's a vast change you know we think
of our bodies as doing what 30 percent
of the exercise that our ancestors did I
think our Jaws my guesstimation is about
five percent of what our Jaws are doing
you can see from the wear of our teeth
and I'm not saying we you know we need
to go back to wearing our teeth down as
our ancestors did but
medicines about treating the cause of
the problem you've got to understand
that cause and of course you know I've
got a strong jaw yes you do I I've that
that my jaw would fit all my teeth quite
happily
and that strong Jaws related to this
strong jaw muscle
you know that the use it or lose it it's
um you know no it's called Wolf's Law
and greater lesser extent that's just
the masseter muscle this here's the
master term the temporalis has come you
don't see the temples but
you know you can Ripple it if you try
but the master does here and
how you know
that strong jaw is related to that
strong muscle and you get strong muscles
from using them
so it's not complex this is relatively
simple
then the next Factor seems to have
changed is we're getting nasal
obstructions and nasal obstructions seem
to have become really commonplace yeah
not really my area but we know they're
going up dramatically people are getting
allergies they're getting blocked noses
it's there's a rapid increase
and
if you can't breathe out of your nose
you'll have two choices you don't
breathe which isn't good
or you're going to
open your mouth to breathe and when you
open your mouth to breathe
you lose that tongue to palate contact
and that's I think it's a really really
vital reflex that we have and you you
lose your lip seal you know and that's a
reflex that's one of the orifices in
your gut don't lose any of those
orifices they're all important
and
if you you but you know as as vital as
those
um re uh reflexes are
breathing's clearly more important you
know breathing's possibly the most
important thing you're going to do you
know that I think that's number one on
my desires today to breathe everything
else comes below that
so to breathe properly you throw away
tongue to Pilot contact you throw away
lip seal now a lot of people regain lip
seal but around puberty because you just
realize this
looks a little stupid you you bring your
lips together but you don't you you
rarely are you gonna get your tongue
back up on the roof of the mouth and
usually yeah
your your pilot's narrowed to the point
where you're gonna struggle to get your
tongue on the river mouth anyway so you
know it becomes a vicious cycle
a lot of people's faces are now so long
they're going to struggle to get their
lips together comfortably and of course
we're creatures of comfort we're only
going to do we will only maintain
as your posture what's comfortable
so we've got these two changes we've
gone from really tough strong muscles
from all this chilling we've gone from
tongue on the palate lips together
and we're now got Wick muscles mouth
open
now does that look familiar
oh that's like uh 80 of school children
are walking around those
you know I take my kids to school and
it's just like I I I just close my eyes
pretend I didn't see it what can you say
to people you know I'm not going to be
in that position and say from hell no by
the way you should be you know they're
going to tell they're going to give me a
flea in the air and tell me where to go
as they rightly should
um
and of course if you hang your mouth
open and you're weak muscles your face
is going to lengthen
and again we go back to that you've got
a stroke you can see that and remember
most people have a stroke it's only the
facial muscles this is surface muscles
and yet that can still create a
relatively pronounced effect and I
remember working in hospitals when I saw
a guy who had had a road traffic
accident and he had severed his
um trigeminal nerve you know the power
nerve that supplies these these muscles
the big muscles it was amazing you know
it was incredible seeing how quickly one
side of his face dropped down
wow and
you know it reminds you just how plastic
faces are but
if your face lengthens because yeah hang
your mouth open with weak muscles it's a
little bit like one of those children's
toys heads and they're just being
stretched so it gets narrower and it
gets shallower and you reduce the
cross-sectional area
so horrifying I know I know he was
talking about kids you know it just well
you know what you know what has my blood
when I see this but oh yeah that's
crooked teeth AKA male occlusion
crowding yeah
when uh when Scarlett so I have a
five-year-old yeah and uh she used a
Soother when she was little
and I didn't know
I know I don't I didn't know yeah but
don't beat yourself up about this
because you know myself beating myself
up
yeah you know and there's there's lots
you can do now so
um my grandfather so I'm a third
generation orthodontist
my grandfather was taught by Harold
Chapman in the UK and Harold Chapman was
the guy who made Orthodontics he pushed
Orthodontics into being a science you
know evidence base well in that
direction we didn't get evident based
idea until a little bit later
but he pushed it to being scientific and
he still you know there's a Harold
Chapman prize with the British
orthodontic Society runs and so what he
told my grandfather was that four or
five years old if you didn't have enough
space between all the operand sizes
so you know you've got the upper and
sizes here's a cast so you'd have space
and I think it was actually between the
K9 as well so you'd have the Gap there
the Gap there the Gap there the Gap
there and the Gap there so that's five
spaces I believe
and
if four or five years old you didn't
have the space for a half crown
now that is about two millimeters thick
wow then you were going to have problems
in the future
and he recommended doing a burst of
expansion
um to kick the kids out of this hole
they were in and I did it for both my
kids and if you implement that with some
really good functional exercises then it
can really be really beneficial to kids
yeah what is so what does that look like
what do you do for kids
widen them so basically you just look at
the top of this Appliance top of this
Appliance you can see you've got a screw
in the middle of it yeah and you can put
that in the roof of a child's mouth and
widen them wow from where the way child
what the way Harold Chapman was talking
it's it's relatively clear I think that
this was relatively rare
so most children would have that much
space which is literally 10 millimeters
and yet I see no kids with that much
space anymore
no one you know I never see it it would
be you'd treat every child that walks in
hmm and
that reflects the amount of change that
we've had just in a hundred years you
know Harold Chapman was teaching my
father maybe in the well you might
uh throughout the 20s so my grandfather
started just before the war first World
War III signed up joined the first world
war got shot up came back finished his
education after the war so it was that
era First World War era
and
you know I don't I think we we it's so
easy just to forget how things were and
become accommodated to how things are
now so speaking of how to look good eat
meat feed your kids meat introduce your
babies to meet as a first food so they
don't just survive on soft foods and
have underdeveloped jaws and end up as
ugly individuals I eat low histamine
meat from betterfed.com and with code MP
you can get 20 off your first order if
you do have histamine intolerance so you
get sweaty after eating aged meat or
your stomach doesn't feel right they
have unaged beef available to you now
this is extremely hard to come by most
beef is aged so check it out because
their stock is limited if you don't have
histamine intolerance which is it's a
better way to be they also have amazing
just regular aged meat a study by North
Dakota State University founded their
beef Anya beef to be as tender as
American wagyu but at a fraction of the
price better fed beef is made up of 17
Midwest Farm families who raise and care
for the cattle and are also owners in
the business
this is what I eat and love and I can
pretty much choose whatever meat to eat
and I like these guys so visit
betterfedbeef.com use the promo code MP
at checkout for 20 off your first order
so you should make that order a big
order because 20 off is a great deal
betterfedbeef.com real beef from real
families making Jaws look better since 2
million years ago so how do you solve
because I have two things that I
definitely want to cover which would be
one if you're an adult and you want to
become more attractive or fix your jaw
or get a stronger jaw what exactly do
you do
okay so this is the big multi-million
dollar question I
um Julia I'm I I my core business has
always been treating kids and trading
kids really young I much prefer you know
our motto is Eight's getting too late
for treatment
so I much prefer younger kids of four
years old I often do just as little
burst of expansion
and kids when they're developing they
are so plastic it's it's it's it's it's
it's unbelievable really to watch kids
over about 25 it is really difficult to
change your craniofacial structure
I I gave this lecture in this 21
convention it's the sort of lecture you
know where the Bible research that I
never should have given because it was
all followed by um one of these in cells
and people that
have become apparently I'm a big name
amongst the insiles now I don't know
quietly that
brings to me but
it
I I gave this lecture anyway and at the
end of the lecture I was swamped by
people you you know 19 20 year old
mainly boys
saying okay how can I make my face
better yeah and of course that it wasn't
actually what was going through my head
just just with exercises and I was kind
of saying to them well you know you be
you'd be crazy to try it's a really
difficult thing to do I mean changing
yourself changing your habits is in a
way changing your nature and you know
it's hard to change your nature it is a
whole thing to do
but on the other hand I I guess you'd be
crazy not to try because what else are
you doing with your mouth what I'm
saying is stand up straight and shut
your mouth
yeah this is not rocket science it's not
new this is what I'm saying really is a
reactoration a reworking of ancient
ideas you know this has gone from
Confucius to the victorians all the way
through Society you know the same Mantra
has been running
an important man for that
however
I then seem to start I I
crystallized this thing in people's
minds and people then work really hard
and I've been I've been really really
stunned at some of the images I see from
people yeah of the changes they gain and
it is just they're doing this by Brute
Force they are getting results because
they really want results and for some of
these kids I really feel for them
and I can understand what you know
you know wasn't their fault many of them
were pushed into Orthodontics so they
really didn't want to do in in the
it in the cases that I've seen sometimes
the orthodontics can take the balance
and actually lengthen faces oh and
they're then forced to wear retainers by
their parents we're telling them I paid
for this Orthodontics you've got to wear
the retainers and
they are you know they they I think they
intrinsically know that something's
wrong they see what I'm saying and these
because they feel like they're at the
bottom of the pile they do you know you
we don't
I mean we don't like to talk about it
the fact that that ugly kids are the
unpopular one
because we've had this mentality that
that's his genetic hand and there's
nothing you can do about it and when I
start turning around saying well
actually that's not true there's a lot
you can do about it well these kids
they're jumping on it and they really
you know you think you're the unpopular
one you're the ugly one you're the
you know you I guess there may be made
this is a broad spectrum of why that may
be but you can imagine these kids at
that age are gonna
trans you know fix themselves on trying
to make themselves better they have a
huge level of motivation because
everything in their life is reminding
them about this
and they really focus and they really
get then they gain changes and I'm
really stunned with that and of course
they're thinking oh well I'm looking
better and I'm thinking you're healthier
mm-hmm
this is really going to help you in your
life
now my mission is to try and
move the needle further north you know
get into slowly get understand how I can
help older and yet older patients
in part with appliances and in part with
exercises
and
you know see if I can change the face of
the world or the faces of the world
because
a lot of people are getting really bad
health issues from this
yeah and crooked teeth is just it's One
symptom
you know when you you look at I can put
a picture of an ancestral upper jaw so
you know here's a patient I've treated
and you can see that's a big wide upper
jaw yeah and my I I like I for me my
mark of success is when the wisdom teeth
come in and when the wisdom teeth come
in at around 18 years old because that's
when they should come in and there
should be space for them
and then you know if he gets wisdom
teeth coming he's got you know not you
know he's got a really big upper jaw now
that's a lot of space for your tongue
are getting kids coming or older
patients coming in and they've had a
premolar extracted and they're also
missing their wisdom teeth so that's
four premolars four wisdom teeth and
they're slightly crowded
where's the space for their tongue
there's no space in it you can see that
the the face isn't well developed
there's no space for the tongue and then
where's the tongue well
they seem to have a high chance of
having sleep apnea
because where else is the tongue going
to go you know this is the house for the
town if you lack space here your
tongue's falling in the back of your
Airway
and that would appear to be what sleep
apnea is and I see people I've been to
sleep apnea meetings and they're talking
about you know
all of these different potential causes
and the categorizing that's what you
know people got to research for a search
or die you've got to come up with papers
saying
something and they're categorizing and
I'm saying well haven't someone noticed
here's an ancestral draw here's an
ancestral draw and here's a modern jaw
they're vastly different and until
you've excluded this massive I mean
massive change in form well surely all
your other categorizations are going to
come second to this huge change in
facial form
and yeah I I just I'm well you know
I've been trying just to get any form of
scientific engagement you know it just
you know so when
um
2009 I wrote an article I want to look
it up the Black Swan by Mike new where I
challenge the British Orthodontics I
said look you know we had a debate I
think it was in 1937 held by the general
Dental Council you know the main
regulator the the government body in
charge of Dentistry the board if you
wish
and they held that debate on
the Ecology of malocclusion why are
teeth crooked now you know that was 1937
maybe we should have another debate and
that's what I was saying to my regulator
you know we should have a debate on this
because this is this is important stuff
you know if we've got retreating
you know
I think at least 50 I mean if the people
who can afford it I think it's way
higher than that you know I had a girl
who came in and she said every other
girl or every other person in her class
had braces on she was the only one
without racism well she had one of my
braces in so that means that's 100 in
that class 100 of the people all are
having some you know white invasive just
because everyone's happy yeah done
it doesn't mean this isn't really quite
an invasive procedure to have done in a
credibly sensitive part of your body
and
this is being done while my specialty
the orthodontic specialty opened admits
it has basically no idea why teeth are
crooked
foreign
so I said okay well you know there's
situations where we've pressed ahead in
medicine where we don't understand the
answers but we should be ready at a drop
of a hat to engage in that conversation
and drive conversation forward
well after my
um
article in the British Dental Journal
I then had a letter writing campaign I
wrote to the all the government bodies
you know the minister of Health the
all-party dental committee the um
uh
uh quango above the general Dental
Council the general Dental Council I
think Forge heads
um the Royal Society the I I I I you
know everyone I wrote yeah everyone
because you know I wanted to make a
meaningful Challenge and I've just
I I I think I exhausted all possible
Avenues to engage in the scientific
process
I'm saying all I want is a scientific
process I don't believe I'm right you
know don't don't believe a word I'm
saying but you know what we've achieved
you know here we go you know fantastic
things we've achieved my ability to talk
to you right now yeah and this has all
been done by adherence to the scientific
process you know finding out what works
and you know I thought medicine you know
medicine was supposed to be about trying
to find answers and yet no one but no
one has engaged with me and I've had
some really odd responses from senior
orthodontists on we don't really need to
know
of course in their point they don't need
to know because they can make teeth
straight
and that's even for the answer to make
peace straight
and I'm saying okay well you can make
them straight but they don't stay there
yeah asking people to wear retainers the
rest of their life well that's not
really fixing something
you know have I got a builder if I had a
leak in the roof and I've got to build
around I said we'll fix that leak and he
goes all right it's all done mate yeah
done done but if it rains you need to
put a tarpaulin over the top
okay
I'm going
sorry I thought you fixed it
you know you go back thousands of years
a bit more than a thousand let's say
people had perfectly straight teeth from
when they're born
well not clearly when the teeth erupted
to when they die and that that was
normal in all humans and it was
generally true in all the other 5 400
species of mammals
and he only released him for it's become
endemic it's almost become normal it's
been normalized
because it's happened to everyone and
it's always that risk that you start
looking around at what normal is
and you think that
it's normal
well it is normal but it is not ideal
and we're reeking the the issues
of you know
a face that's not the right shape
doesn't work properly
and you know I I can often you know I
okay
so I went to see a well-respected ear
nose and throat surgeon so that would be
Auto laryngologist
in the US
and I said to him as I've said in an
lecture before I've said I thought that
10 of the people over 16 were going to
be dying 10 years early because of sleep
apnea and his consequences yikes
and he said
oh my it's more like 20 oh great
and I just I just it just staggers me so
you've got
a fifth of the population dying from
sleep apnea now sleep apnea was not in
my syllabus when I qualified as a
dentist in 93
now it's killing yeah a fifth of a
population a decade early
so what what does that mean what does
that mean killing us like is it
contributing to other health problems
that are killing people you know sleep
time because what's happening in sleep
apnea is you know you breathe in you
breathe out you breathe in you'll
breathe out you've got so little space
that when you breathe in your tongue
gets pulled in to your Airway
so what your body's done is gonna suck a
little bit harder and you try sucking a
little bit harder and clearly that's not
going to work because it's so hard you
suck the more your tongue is going to
get in your Airway so then you need to
wake up
stimulate your conscious musculature
to pull your tongue out your Airway and
then you go back to sleep again well
this broken sleep pattern seems to be
really caustic for all of the body
systems I mean everything you know just
basically your body starts falling apart
Young
and um
it's
yeah I mean it's a big worry it really
worries me particularly when I look at
the fact that you know you go you Google
back
1960 1980s
because those are the guys you know 19
yeah 1980s because those are the guys
are going to be 20 then who are 60 now
and look at 20 year olds on photographs
and from my observation and from the
orthodontic need at the time it would
appear
that they had a far lower
incidents well we don't think they had
sleep apnea because it wasn't in my
syllabus but they seem to have great
facial forms much better facial forms
that I'm seeing on the street now yeah
so that would indicate if that's true
that it's 20 now in a decade it'll be 30
or 25 percent a decade after that if
more and more and more and more until
someone wakes up to the fact that yes
our faces are not growing correctly and
that's having a major impact
and of course
so that's in the sleep apnea and the
elderly when you look at sleep apnea on
the kids
were
ah well
Stephen Sheldon in Chicago is saying
that there's no such thing as ADHD
it's kids who can't who have got short
sleep
what do you give to kids who have ADHD
given amphetamines keep them up
also
he did an experiment well it's not
difficult you know yeah he had a load of
kids who they sleep deprived a group of
kids for an experiment you know they've
got ethics to do that and he you know
the research for phones and marketing
says please never ever ever ask me to do
this experiment again yeah oh because a
room full of sleep deprived kids is just
crazy
um kids that are very short of sleep
well they're acting
a little bit like kids with ADHD
so here's this crossover and we're
thinking oh isn't it interesting all
spectral issues are going up like this
yeah sleep apnea going up like this male
occlusion going up like this jaw joint
problems going up like this
um poor post your body posture because
you know if you can't you don't have
enough space to Breathe Here
well you can open your mouth hang your
tongue out that's a good way of getting
around it also you can hold your head
forward
oh
I'm suggesting it's not just it's not
just phone use then I I think that's not
helping certainly not helping but for
most people most people you know you get
your average person and ask them to
stand up straight so that your earlobes
over your traps over your trapezius and
by the time they've got their head back
there they've got no Airway
you know you could say to them you could
say to them stand up straight till
you're blue in the face
and they're gonna you know they're gonna
have you know the angel on the side
going oh yeah you know he's he's
absolutely right
you know that's what we should be doing
yeah I clear it makes sense you know
Mike says it everyone's saying great
great I want to stand up straight and
you've got the devil on the other side
that says please yeah
what's good what are you gonna remember
I couldn't focus on something for a good
five minutes before my attention wanders
yeah no you know you're not going to
maintain an uncomfortable posture so
your head's going to drop forwards
and you know maybe I'm wrong but you
know don't believe a word I'm saying but
believe in my desire to find out
and starting with why
are teeth crooked and then we work up so
then the next thing I did because
clearly I didn't get my debate you know
five years of letter writing out no one
wanted the debate
and so then I start wanting to map out
the pathological process because my
father would come up with all these
ideas it was really interesting no one
would ever talk to him no one has ever
given my father a meaning scientific
meaningful scientific engagement
you know the the the philosopher of
science
he said that you know one of the
problems is when you start controlling
the means of communication within a
science
and you start excluding people so people
don't all get access to the means of
communication and that's the history of
science Medical Science particularly you
just you go you know okay you know I've
I've been fascinated in in your story
you know um
you know you've gone against medical
Doctrine completely against medical
Doctrine and you must have stopped and
thought well hang around why didn't
someone you know all of the stuff you
went through as a child no one ever said
to you oh by the way could you consider
this
yeah yeah not once they said don't
consider this actually when we said
should we definitely not yeah
you know because I'm I'm I've got I tell
you
okay I've got here I went through the
dress but I've got to help
some worms
and I'm planning to infect myself
my Crohn's disease
whoa okay you haven't tried it yet I
haven't tried it I don't know I've done
any ride today I'm just sitting I mean
you know the really scary thing is you
you I think you get a patch and you put
the patch on your arm
and the worms make it to your gut oh my
gosh
you know but what what's modern medicine
done you know I've had two I've been
I've been disemboweled twice
I am
being oh I'm clearly this this the the
court case had come on me or is it just
immense stress yeah immense and of
course the big problem here the the
underlying reason why I'm not getting
anywhere with this treatment is because
people
have tried it they realize it it doesn't
make money
changing People doesn't make money
you know you've got the my old example
of this is who makes money a dietitian
or a liposuction
because one drives a Ferrari the other
rides a bicycle
and one's probably on all the Committees
in the hospital
and the other one just sees the new you
know the committee decided this on you
know on the email they were sent
because one's bringing the Box in and
yet who's really doing the health
benefit here
I don't know dietitians are The
dietitian yeah because that's clearly
what's going to make the health benefit
but fixing things makes money
so clearly no one wants to do this this
technique is in it's really difficult
and I've I've bust a gut over the last
10 years you know I've worked
exceptionally hard you know to the point
where I've damaged my health
and this court case has then further
damaged yet and yeah I can't really make
money out of this
you know so it's not going to fly
there's treatment I've got it's you know
I believe that I could take any young
child
and grow them into a beautiful person or
should I say my words growing into a
healthy person
and that's my belief that's the premise
of what I'm saying
but I need you know I I can't charge
enough sensibly to cover the costs of
doing that I can I mean I run this claim
by reducing my wage breakdown so by
reducing my wage right down I'm working
really hard I can run the clinic and
then I hit with a court case and bang
all my savings have gone
um and my health is just my Crohn's
diseases
you know
might just just ramping up my Crohn's
disease so
um
you know it's
yeah I'm in a bit of a hole sometimes
but you know
one of the nice things is that this
mewing thing
seems to have taken off and that's for
sure yeah that's for sure
um
you know it's it's it's it's it's crazy
I I you know to try and get a metric a
handle on how well this mewing has been
doing
um I well someone pointed it out to me
and since I've been Googling uh but not
Googling checking the tick tock because
on Tick Tock people put these hashtags
so now the hashtag mewing has been
viewed or videos that have the hashtag
viewing has been viewed
to date
2.1 billion times
which is just just absolutely insane
and so clearly there's a huge interest
in this
and so I'm going to put a mewing app out
and I was not quite ready but it should
be out soon because most of this Mo you
know I I again I'm drawing parallels
with your father here I had a list of
videos for my patients
so that I didn't have to describe this
lots of times
and having given this lecture people
jump on the videos I I had for my
patients and the rest of them history
but I've not really given my full
account of what you could do to improve
yourself
and
so I hope I'm hoping that I can monetize
the mealing app and then I can
cross-subsidize my clinic and
you know I I'm trying to I'm trying to
do science here and that's a really
really hard thing to do with just zero
help from the establishment
you know
it's it's you know what this is I've got
a public we have a public health care
System here
there are scientists full-time salaried
researchers whose job it is
to
hunt out
comments from the clinicians
and look into things in Greater detail
and research things
well I'm I'm completely excluded from
this process
you know there's a the biggest
um orthodontic training program is
literally I reckon you could make it
door-to-door on the train in about 25
minutes from here
and yeah you know I've been trying to
talk to the professor for what
six years just trying to get the you
know just get a little pilot study going
or something
and
it's but yeah but the way we're talking
here people are talking about
um you know science you're supposed to
compare the same thing we're comparing
apples and pears because
I'm not trying to make tea straight
yeah I'd love them to demonstrate but
all I do is I heard them into general
areas and then I work on improving
facial form
now
I expect the patience to largely make
their own teeth straight
now I'm never going to compete with the
fixed braces that make the teeth
straight
I'm not in the same ballpark I can't
but if a patient makes their own teeth
straight
they're liable to stay straight
maybe I don't get such a perfect result
but they're liable to stay straight
if someone else makes your teeth
straight
they're unliable to stay there and
that's exactly what we see
so people put retainers in and I'm
I worry that retainers are holding teeth
out the balance Zone
the holding teeth out of where they want
to go now you can do that with a
retainer that can hold the teeth
but can you also hold the bone out there
and the supporting tissues
because the evidence probably says no
and we just you know we haven't been on
this Mass Orthodontics bandwagon for
that long
and this relatively recent push for
permanent retainer lifelong retention
it's a relatively new thing
and I clearly have my worries about that
and you know I would love to engage some
people in meaningful debate on this
that's what I want you know any
Professor on the planet please take up a
platform with me so that we can have
meaningful engagement about my concerns
because yeah well it's reasonable but
that's I think that's more than
reasonable it makes way more sense than
it's just
medical system can be crazy because it
makes way more sense that something's
wrong
then oh it's just suddenly genetic it
just suddenly changed and now everyone
needs braces because humans have evolved
with braces yeah and when you you know I
when people say to me you know they will
say oh well it is racial mixing you know
mommy's small Jewels but Daddy sorry
that's that's clearly been proven to be
wrong that's a good one you know I mean
things research you know why you know he
was taking thousands of people he
clearly demonstrates that's not the case
and you know any geneticist would laugh
that out
but yeah it it's these ideas just get
perpetuated because I said so often
so how do you so if you have a kid how
do you make sure that their teeth are
going to fit in their mouth and that
they're okay so if we're going to take a
picture starting from like zero yeah so
if we're going to take a purely
preventative option
yeah well I mean
I try I'm trying I really don't
understand what's going on below about
three four years old I mean I'd want to
take some time off really investigate
this and look at cases because it's not
something really people looked at and of
course
people are not born with teeth
usually so you know I would love to just
look at skulls and
3D scan lots and lots of people to see
see what's happening
let's say I was giving advice to you now
as a mother of a five-year-old okay so I
have my five point prevention strategy
the first is stand up straight and shut
your mouth
you know which horsebacks to your dad's
first rule
you know although he's just saying stand
up yeah there's I think there's a little
bit more subtlety but you know
we could go into that but
the second thing is
um
uh eat with your mouth shut
and this is something so you sit
directly opposite your child
and you can sit there so what I well the
one I did last night with my child I sat
there opposite
um daughter number
two who's six years old she wanted to
watch something on the phone so I sat
there with the phone and every time her
lips were apart or she didn't sit up
straight I just
like that
and she knew it so I would prompted her
the first few times and pretty soon you
know she got it
and all I had to sit there doing this
every time she didn't sit up straight
and you know what I'm saying to her
is that her lips should only separate
for the fork to go the food to go in the
mouth
and you should have a relatively small
amount of food in the mouth going in at
one time not a huge amount you've got a
relatively small bite in your mouth then
the lips go closer all of the
all of the extended
actions should be done with the lip seal
you're training the lips to be together
and you simply sit opposite them make
sure you've got every single meal
they've got their lips together
all the time
and that's a hell of a thing to do
Michaela you know you're a mom you know
how busy it is you know how chaotic it
is and you've got to sit there at as
many meals as a humanly possible I would
suggest the evening meals would be a
great thing to do it and you make sure
that they're sitting up straight you
know
you know this you know they say that if
you do a Brisk 10 minute walk every day
you reduce the chance of a
cardiovascular a heart attack
you know it's really really pushing this
in the UK I don't know they're saying
that in the US at the moment but they're
encouraging the elderly Community to
have a Brisk 10 minute walk well if I
could get young children
from as young as possible to do
30 to 40 minutes exercise from this
young age this would be
you know really powerful
when are we using the mouth
when we're eating so I've got this super
secret exercise
can't tell anyone
the meal time exercise
sit up straight
elbows off the table
eat with your mouth shut
chew your food properly
don't speak when you're eating food to
you not you to your food
and when you go to swallow pause chin
tuck bite together and swallow well
apart from that last bit I threw in
that's probably the least secret
exercise on the planet
I've
I've had people coming
for consultations with me
from all over the world from all
different groups
and
Everyone by one person who was brought
up in the Amazon jungle with out tables
and chairs
they all had that exercise in their
Collective memory their cultural memory
now that's
because
it worked so for as I said from
Confucius was saying exactly that right
through the victorians to being every
culture and all of these cultures are
saying exactly the same thing
and you think well actually that's
really weird
that's either that's magic or there's a
room yeah yeah yeah important thing why
they're saying that and it's because it
worked and back in those days when
someone didn't grow well it was obvious
because everyone else did grow well
so from that book the the the the
low-lying fruit on that is eat with your
lips together
if you can get your childhoods with lip
together you you're making massive
inroads then I'd recommend chew gum from
when they come home after school
until they go to bed
chew gum
the whole time
and I'd go for a tougher gum than usual
then of lip tape at night you know
clearly you check for some medical
advice I don't want to be suggesting
this to people who may have other
conditions but go online check situation
see your doctor check it's fine but then
just simple lip taping across the lips
um
so I you'll normally recommend
microportate to be used at night I often
use this one here which is if you can
see that it there's microbial silicon
this tape this table like don't start
night times for The Kid
start in the daytime because you've got
suddenly give them tape never put tape
on your child while they're asleep you
need there they need to be abort into
this they need to want to do that so you
start with this blue tape and this blue
tape is great
because of course you can put this on
someone's lips
you can take it off
put it somewhere where you might need it
in the future
and then next time right
well next time they want to watch a
device
they have the device and the lip tape
has to go on but because the lip takes
ah you don't have to go to the drawer
it's right here or you can stick it to
the kitchen cupboards you've got it
there and when they're watching the
phone they've got to have a lip tape on
that's such a good idea and then once
they're used to that and once you've
you've done some you know you've set up
a you know you find out what I'm sure
that sure there's something they want to
watch on the phone
and
you then you you set a maybe a film or
something and they've got to have
um oh sorry
they've got to have the lip tape on for
the duration
of this movie
and or they can't watch the movie and
that's gonna be enough of incentive for
them to do it and then one they're
finished
or then we'll once I've done that once
or twice then you can consider lip
taping at night
and what I also then did was for the
kids the kids often get up before me
they come into my bedroom say can I have
your phone and I'll say if they've got
the lip tape on yes you haven't got your
lip tape on no
so then they're gonna have the lip tape
on
um so what we did my pipeline prevention
chew gum All of Me lip tape
eat your meals
with your lips together
and then
um remind them always to stand up
straight and shut your mouth and then
the final point is get good records
it amazes me how people come to see me
and they've got no idea how their
child's face quit in the past got no
decent records you know it's simple with
records if you don't know where you were
you don't know where you're going
this isn't complicated they said this is
every pirate I I actually think every
dentist
should take a sideways photograph you
know a lack of a photograph of every
child in their care every year above the
age of four I'd actually be a mandatory
requirement of all dentists to do that
because this is such an important metric
of of Health
and that's great I think there's so much
you can do you know
yeah I mean and so you can Google it my
five point prevention plan
it's
you know this you know and also why
about this can I put a plug out for our
campaign prevent crooked teeth
and so prevent crooked teeth.com that's
my campaign to try and look into these
prevention you know
why can't we try
to prevent these problems
yeah
we should at least be trying
you know we should be we should be and
so does that mean so say malocclusion is
preventative using those what about diet
what a tough time from a young or
breastfeeding do you think so
breastfeeding yeah I think I think
that's really massively valuable but
what it seems that can really mess
breastfeeding up is the introduction of
soft food
so
you know the first few times you try and
feed your child pureed food they just go
and most of it comes back out again so
you wipe their face off you pick up
another spoon put it in and eventually
they're going to learn to suckle on this
food
so
when we're When We're Young we suckle
and then we're a little bit older we
start to swallow and there should be
this transition between suckling and
swallowing
well what we're doing is we're giving
children
food that's so soft they don't need to
swallow
and we're doing it at such a young pit
point that they're probably not ready to
do a proper swallow
so we train them to make a modified
suckle
and I think about my view about 85 of
the population is doing a modified
suckle
instead of a swallow yeah yeah yeah yeah
so most people you've got a slight
suckle when you swallow so yeah that's
no it did what does that look like
hmm
what does that look like a sweet what's
this difference between a a suckle and a
swallow so wait you're gonna say this is
off so if I'm gonna spoil
okay
yeah and then if I do a modified cycle
oh yeah I don't like that I know what
that is now so so you know so you know I
have water
I'm can I go
okay what is this what does this look
like
I'm smiling too yeah yeah you're smiling
so I can see the little okay okay I'll
try not smiling on down here at the
moment but
did you see that that looked much better
yeah
because then when you think about it
what are you doing to do that you're
having to push your tongue up on the
roof of the mouth
yeah what's going to be the side effect
of that after 10 years
you're not supposed to
oh yeah so that's good okay
I've been I watched some of your videos
the other day
and I I'd heard about mewing a long time
ago I like a long time ago maybe 2016 or
27 like a while ago okay uh and I and I
didn't realize so I've been trying to
practice you know for the last since
2016. and I didn't know that you were
supposed to
put your teeth together
which seems like okay so a bit vital
I've just been pressing my tongue up I
mean without my teeth together it's
awful you shouldn't even actually be
pressing your tongue up what you should
do is you should create a vacuum in your
mouth so your tongue stays up there so
so so princess like okay so now I've got
comfortable posture okay
okay comfortable posture but my tongue's
down
then I'm going to swallow my tongue
swallow several times so I create a
vacuum and my tongue is glued on the
roof of the mouth with the back third
property engaged okay I can't talk
because my tongue will be there but
now
this is my comfortable posture
oh so when you're talking so you know
okay this is my hunch and my belief
is the the back third of the tongue you
know because the front third of the
tongue is from the ectodermal tissues
like you know all the things we think of
as us the back third is the the
endodermal dishes though the bet that
sort of subconscious
and the premise here is that the that
back third is part of the deep cervical
postural muscles or the Ring of muscles
around your neck so that back third of
the tongue is helping keep your head up
right so you have good head posture
and of course as soon as you get that
vacuum going your tongue is going to be
glued to the roof of the mouth
and the net side effect of that is it
your cheekbones the mid face just pushes
out
I just got it
I definitely have not been no no I mean
when when I didn't realize it was a
vacuum that's all you're trying to do
because then you can maintain the vacuum
just by holding lip seal
hmm and there's no effort you see these
things shouldn't take effort
I think I would watch with the mewing
community all these people and you know
I I I kind of purposely held back a
little bit because
you know I I don't want to own all of
this I don't want to be I don't want to
be a I don't micro manage something or
control it that's controlled science
shouldn't be controlled by anyone
science should be free to develop itself
but I you know you know one one of the
reasons I'm doing this mewing app
because I think that there's so much
misinformation out there
yeah the other way is I I need to make
some Revenue you know I wanna
I've got to find answers no one else is
really looking for the answers you know
no one's on this who would be so stupid
is to run their clinic at a loss
work so God damn hard and run all the
risks I'm running
you know
so hopefully with the mewing app I can I
can make some Headway
I can get some funding to do what I'm
doing trying to as I said trying to save
the faces of the world because
you know it is it's not just these young
kids
um it's it's
so much of Humanity's faces are not
growing well
okay last question then I'll let you go
uh for for advice we because you gave a
lot of advice for parents of children
and that's very hopeful yeah what about
what about older people you said above
25 it's very difficult yeah is that
certain like do they need surgery or are
there things they can do okay so surgery
is definitely an option my worry about
the surgery in many instances is the the
surgeons will go and look at well
they've got to know where to put the
Jaws
and what they do is they look back at
these the the x-rays
that were sort of taken as that we we
talk about normative data you know you
need to know what normal is
and all of these X-rays were taken in
the middle of the 1900s early to middle
of 1900s when x-rays became available
well we're talking about disease that
ten thousand years ago didn't exist and
has aggressively got worse in the last I
think it's accelerated in the last 100
years
well
the right near the end point of this
disease you've taken your normative data
so I would challenge
the
the the sort of the the data most
surgeons are using where they are
thinking where to put someone's face
now there are some searches in the U.S
particularly who are really trying to
move faces up and forwards even further
and you know I'm really impressed with
some of the results I know again
Australia I know
um a surgeon in Barcelona I know a
couple in US particularly in the
California Direction and all of them are
really trying to move faces up and
forwards with varying degrees of success
because of course it's more difficult to
do that
but
you know if you're heading for sleep
apnea this is a great fix that can bunny
jump you forwards that can help you to
change your own posture and function
that would be double jar surgery now
there's there's something you know we're
talking about using screws into the bone
to widen the top jaw
as a sort of
halfway house to surgery minor surgical
um interventions and I'm I'm I'm moving
away from that just because
I've got a
a hunk down focus on my core business
stop treating adults for a while because
there's so much heat on me at the moment
and I'm just going to go back to my core
business because you know I'm losing
money
well what can I do you know these adults
come in and they're desperate for me to
drink them and I'm saying I couldn't
touch you because you know from at
orthodontist would criticize me for
providing the treatment is one of the
cases against me you know one of the
case against me you know parents are
Overjoyed with the treatment I've done
probably one of the most
you know what we've done I believe is
one of the most beneficial things he's
done in her life
and they're taking me to court
oh well you know in other case I didn't
even treat so you
you know and the third case is the
British orthodontical Society has gone
through my videos found things they
don't like about it
and really put really in a really quite
harsh way referred me to my regulator so
you know I I there's two high risks to
run and also you know I I just want to
go down to my core business for a while
reduce my clinical hours because I'm not
making money and then see if I can make
money from
well the luck I've had with knewing and
somehow from online presence if I could
make money then and then I'll just cycle
it back into the clinic and sponsor the
research that I would love that's a good
idea you know universities to be helping
me with but they're not helping me
so what do I do
that's a good yeah that's a good idea
yeah
as I said the only people really
interested in what I'm saying are people
with faces
but if you happen to have a face this is
utterly fascinating this is Uber
fascinating
and you know eventually you know when
when the Sultan of Vermont really
realizes the value of what I'm doing or
I wish the royal family in the UK
they would who were they going to send a
kid to and then money suddenly becomes
No Object you know if you really want
your children child to grow well
you know you know irrele irrespective of
the cost of that well
you know
that's what I'm trying to do
but
okay Mike
I don't know well I don't know you've
got a lot of views on Tick Tock I think
that you can make this work with the app
good luck
as I said it is stress it's so stressful
I would love to be doing what your
father's doing and trying to use the
case against me
flip it back to to highlight the
I've got to be careful my words here
the Highlight this situation
you know fewer words because but you
know it's it's really hard because all
the lawyers just say be quiet be quiet
be quiet
so you know you don't get much help
yeah
and nothing's going to change either
exactly I mean this is the problem
whenever someone gets under the
spotlight of the regulator
they are told and no one's certain terms
have got to be absolutely storm not say
anything
and
then they're gay
removed by the regulator and no one
knows
what danger are you even other people
with an entire profession
and remember okay yes that
but to an individual to an individual
there's no danger posed with I will say
if you change your password
would have grown like that anyway and
I'm just milking the parents for
um unnecessary treatment and as
necessary appliances
so and you know
also of course you can read from you
know when you read the transcript of the
prosecuting expert I
um you know in
insulting his profession
um
you know you can see it's a visceral
dislike of what I'm saying you can see
that in the wording of what he says
it's um
you know the people don't like that and
of course then then this is this this
you know the really big story
is that sometimes and I don't say it
happens all the time modern Orthodontics
May and actually it does sometimes
retract the face and it causes a
downswing in facial form
now if that's happening
then you're going to
in Chuck increase the chance of sleep
apnea which means you could potentially
make someone live less along
you're gonna potentially cause you know
you have the risks of childhood sleep
apnea which is reduced intelligence I
mean that's quite well mapped out by
David Gonzalez and lots of other people
and then you've got the fact they're
going to be less attractive
now
you've gone along to an orthodontist
he's not warned you about these possible
side effects
it's an elective procedure that you
didn't need to have done
and you can you know just talking about
the subject is just stirring up The
Hornet's Nest and you know people will
hate me just for mentioning this now
and
you know I don't want to definitively
say this happens all the time
um I do I would like to point out that
my father was on National Television in
the UK in 98 saying that he felt
orthodontist could damage faces and of
course he was
basically excommunicated at that point
and he has now lost his license himself
but
all I'm saying is we need we need open
debate on this
I'm saying I'm right I'm just we need
meaningful
so I say full fair and free debate where
everyone gets invited
you know the American Association of
Orthodontics had a special meeting to
cover this risk of sleep apnea and where
the orthodontics causes sleep apnea well
the people most of them you know
Disciples of my fathers who you know
like someone like Bill hang who did more
to raise this issue of sleep apnea from
extractions and retraction than anyone
wasn't invited to speak
so well you know and he you ask him for
his opinion on that event
it doesn't smell good
and again I would like just meaningful
debate on that
that's all I want is I want engagement I
want the scientific process remember
don't believe a word I say believe in
the scientific process believe in my
desire for scientific engagement because
I want answers I desperately want
answers
I'm running you know I'm running it's a
purist system in this Clinic as I can to
gain
the best possible outcomes but changing
People doesn't make money
QED where can people go online to find
you to find me
yeah social media websites please don't
I get more miles than I can cope with
I mean I'm you know I'm just not really
prepared I'm
you know I I'm hoping you know because
because it's well I I orthodontist
flippantly go oh just do some research
you know just do that
you know when you're working so hard and
you've got so limited resources it's
really really hard to go and do
meaningful research on this and then
what do I prove well they're getting
straight to teeth and I am and they
won't show the faces every time I've
suggested or so they go we're going to
look at the teeth but no we can't show
the faces because that would be
breaching confidentiality oh crazy and I
go well if you ask the patients whether
they mind
because you might find that's going to
go fine
I don't mind all I want is you know one
thing about time and time again over the
years is to have some comparative
research so I say you take 10 cases I'll
take 10 cases we'll have an independent
assessor who has the name and address of
the patients in case they opt out
treatment so he can independently check
why they dropped out
and we follow the cases for 10 years
after the treatment and just see what
happens
you know this would cost but minimum
amount because you're treating the
patients anyway
and you don't have to have exactly
matched patients because it's just an
exploratory trial
and I've been asking for what 30 years
we've been asking for this
30 years I remember my father
um asking one group of more alternative
orthodontists
and the
person he organized the head of the
group came back with a message from
someone the message was all John Mew
wants to do is show off his good facial
outcomes
laughs
are you working you go I mean I I've
never had a really meaningful engagement
with any orthodontic
orthodontist of no ever you know I
always hold me when I was at University
I had to hold back what I'm saying
because I just upset people
and you know
people can come you know I'm apparently
I'm the known charlatan yeah yeah of
course
well a lot of people are listening
though like you might not you might not
have won through the the scientific
Community or The Regulators but I mean
people are paying attention
yes yeah I mean I I I've guessed
I guess I'm gonna have to monetize this
because otherwise I don't get the reach
that I need to change the world
yeah plus there's nothing wrong with
monetizing if you're going to be helping
people and if you're avoiding like
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars of Orthodontics anyway
potentially
that's really saving money yeah you know
again you know what I want to my my
always main focus has been prevention
you know I want to go forward working
out treatments you know I I don't claim
my treatment's the best I'm my official
version of my treatment is my treatment
is terrible it's only better than the
Alternatives that's great that sounds
like my dad I I yes yeah you know thank
you okay well Mike it was very nice
meeting you when you do have your app up
and running I'll link it in this video
so people can check it out because
well thank you very much indeed yeah
thanks for coming on
[Music]